the process we just went through will
repeat but running saga a second time
will create a totally new execution
context instead of referencing the
original blue context this accommodates
for storage of different bindings as
ever the interpreters lookup focus will
also shift into the newly created
context the VAR declaration creates a
new variable in this new context and if
you like to think about the storage
layout that language is used for your
data you could say that this variable is
stored in a new distinct location from
the first one now while this isn't
necessarily the case it's likely true
and it's a useful way to think about it
what values do you expect to be logged
by this line given the current in memory
conditions